I want to briefly talk about the Donald
Trump anti-abortion order you might
remember that two days after the women's
March Donald Trump signed this executive
order which band US foreign aid to any
health organization that provides or
even discusses abortions with women as
usual it's mostly optics because health
organizations were already not allowed
to use federal money to fund abortions
but now organizations that receive
federal funding aren't even allowed to
provide abortions that are funded by
other sources not exactly small
government conservative is it and to be
super clear here even if Donald Trump
hadn't signed this anti abortion order
federal tax dollars still wouldn't have
gone to fund abortions either way this
is just a way for Trump to help restrict
women's access to abortions in the
general sense Ronald Reagan originally
signed this order Bill Clinton repealed
it George W Bush then re-enacted it
Barack Obama then repealed it is the
epic political pendulum that that's
going on here and many people are
calling it the Global gag rule because
it prevents many organizations from even
counseling women about abortion
procedures or even referring women to
someone else about them they are not
allowed to even discuss the procedure
and what many people in the u.s. don't
get particularly the people that are
cheerleading this is that international
health organizations are more reliant on
monetary aid from the US than any other
country and this is going to result in a
number of organizations losing their
funding and this is Trump's far right
anti-abortion ideology having
consequences in the real world some of
us believe that Trump is not really
anti-abortion right now he's been
pro-choice his entire life others
believe like Sarah Palin stated on the
campaign trail that Trump has seen the
light and he truly is anti-abortion now
really doesn't matter Pat because people
are being negatively affected by this
whatever Trump believes he signed this
and that has an impact no and this also
comes on the day where Donald Trump's
going to announce his appointee to the
Supreme Court yeah and I think there's a
litmus test there that they have to be a
homemaker of overturning Roe vs. Wade
Planned Parenthood of ghana lost
hundreds of thousands and
funding and had to cut forty four
percent of their nursing staff and
disaffected 1300 communities in Ghana as
a result of this regulation being active
during the Bush administration just an
example of how this has real-world
impact but here's the real kicker the
order which has been tried and tested
for decades does not decrease abortion
check out this study from Stanford
University which actually point out that
these are not regulations that
effectively reduce the number of
abortions that are happening you you
have either less safe abortions take
place you have the so-called back-alley
abortion you have abortions continued by
these organizations just without having
to refuse or distance themselves from
aid from the United States but this is
yet another reason why we should be
opposed to these types of regulations
because they don't reduce the number of
abortions sex education as well as
access to contraception reduce the
number of abortions right-wingers are
predominantly opposed to those ideas
very very sad and this is really going
to hurt real people it's not just
politics and Trump making a show of
signing and holding up executive orders
discuss this with us on reddit at david
pakman.com slash r ed di t gamefly is
sort of like netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low use price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you would return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s